oh hey how's your breasts
welcome to parappa the rapper it's been
it's been wait calm down game oh [ __ ]
sake it's been it's been three years
since I played this game on this channel
I saw the comment a lot of people are
like still waiting for part 4 and I'm
like yeah that game was [ __ ] awesome
why did I not finish it and then I
replayed everything so I can make a vid
out of it and I'm like oh yeah that's
why this game is [ __ ] impossible so
this is the level we left off on I'm
well excited to [ __ ] try it out at
least we'll have some fun revisit some
memories like I even have the same
haircut I had three years ago nothing
has changed
god damn okay yeah this is the song
about taking a [ __ ] in case you haven't
realized I would remember just a
father's ooh what I hunt this morning I
don't even wanna say to you kick kick
punch time chunk the door oh ah before
dude it's all buddy that Network kick
punch the [ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ] place is
the working book dick dick you take the
dick I don't understand this [ __ ]
game
did you check the College of the right
nice I'm about to [ __ ] my pants brows
[ __ ] you've got a funky flow but now you
really odd it off but yeah go ahead and
[ __ ] your pants you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] that is not even pants what is this
they made this gaming pain I swear to
God everything from the 90s was just
made in paint what is this [ __ ] going
inside him what is this
did he pee his pants what did he do with
his pants okay let's try this again it's
okay it's okay just as far the zoo what
I hug this morning I don't even wanna
say to you why I don't understand now go
ahead and [ __ ] your pants you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
how am I getting worse this game makes
no sense I know I seem like a 12 year
old who complained at the games fold but
it is the game's fault
what spread again
that's pretty [ __ ] good I don't
understand this [ __ ] game I really
don't understand this [ __ ] game I
played it for [ __ ] hours I don't
understand the buttons watch my Preston
go just as far the zoo what I hunt this
morning I don't even wanna say to you I
do it wrong did you check it on the left
did you [ __ ] the [ __ ] down the rock
did you count the [ __ ] [ __ ]
what's that am I having fun yeah press
I'm say we're gonna do it do we do we
I don't understand
Russ I need your help help me kick punch
bow or tuck the goal did you check the
corner on the right did you check
[ __ ] killing it no okay okay
No ribbit ribbit I can't hold it I'm
rather that I had a beverage holder okay
[ __ ] you then
chicken [ __ ] I am a [ __ ] a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] a [ __ ] a [ __ ] a [ __ ] a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] you know I got to go oh yeah open
up you know [ __ ] got a sick is rapper
labra I am a bit in the ass I [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the ass
no don't say that might fix the gun you
know I gotta go
go get opened up you know it's all yours
oh oh [ __ ] I've never been so happy to
take a [ __ ] of a laugh Wow sorry to keep
you waiting hmm I'll Drive you home now
Bruce hmm he's the same old parappa
again oh well why because I don't know
how to nail that [ __ ] I'm so happy
Russ if I finish this next one that
means I finish your let's play that took
three years to make this is the most
amazing thing that's ever happened to
you I got a believe [ __ ] oh oh
well can you feel it oh it's really
there girl
there's anywhere Oh
just do it down
okay enough of that [ __ ] [ __ ] last
song Bruce yo yo go check this out
by the time blue feeling [ __ ] it all
right I'm hoping I got a believe I got a
believe we got a believe you gotta
believe hey yo yo I got a [ __ ] [ __ ]
dick in the ass what the works it comes
to do and now he's running up and down
the street oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] I got a
believe
that went does that work
[ __ ] this game externa Arthur Arthur
[ __ ] you sound like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] robot maybe next time
maybe next time ain't gonna be no next
time the flower died [ __ ] yeah you gotta
believe I got a believe sure I gotta
believe I gotta believe I gotta believe
I got a believe [ __ ] if I hear it I
gotta believe one more [ __ ] time I
got a [ __ ] [ __ ] myself
No
I gotta believe you gotta believe